BRAVE ENOUGH TO DO THAT.
LISA, YOU ARE BRAVE.
>> HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
>> Tucker: ISSUING SAD
APOLOGIES FOR THEIR OWN SKIN
COLOR, WARNING THAT IF YOU DO
NOT GIVE THEM FULL CONTROL OF
THE U.S. ECONOMY RIGHT NOW, THE
WORLD WILL LITERALLY BE
DESTROYED.
>> THE WORLD IS GOING TO AN END
12 YEARS IF WE DO NOT ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND YOUR BIGGEST ISSUE IS --
[APPLAUSE]
YOUR BIGGEST ISSUE IS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT?
AND LIKE THIS IS THE WAR, THIS
IS OUR WORLD WAR II.
>> THIS IS OUR FINAL CHANCE.
THE SCIENTISTS ARE ABSOLUTELY
UNANIMOUS ON THIS.
THAT WE HAVE NO MORE THAN 12
YEARS TO TAKE INCREDIBLY BOLD
ACTION ON THIS CRISIS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS JUST
PATHETIC.
BUT THE SHOW CARES ABOUT
SCIENCE.
WE WANT TO ASSESS THE CLAIM
CRITICALLY AND SCIENTIFICALLY.
DO WE REALLY HAVE 12 YEARS LEFT?
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
IS IT TRUE.
DANIEL TURNING, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT POWER THE FUTURE,
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
DO WE HAVE 12 YEARS LEFT?
IS THERE SCIENCE THAT SHOWS
THAT?
>> THE ASSOCIATED PRESS DEBUNKED
TO THAT WHICH IS FASCINATING FOR
SOMEBODY WHO STUDIES ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES TO SEE THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS WALK THAT BACK
AND SAY THAT WE HAVE NEVER SAID
THERE ARE 12 YEARS LEFT TO FIX
CLIMATE CHANGE, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS SAID IT, AND
THE SCIENTISTS WHO WRITE THE
REPORT HAVE SAID THAT THAT IS A
MADE-UP STATISTIC THAT YOU ALL
HAVE EXTRAPOLATED.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT THEY
FINALLY --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, THAT IS
THE PARTY OF SCIENCE, WE KNOW
THAT.
THEY HAD A MARCH FOR SCIENCE
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT
ELECTED, THEY BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE, WE DON'T AND WE BELIEVE
OBVIOUSLY IN SNAKE HANDLING.
>> KIDS MARCHED OUT OF CLASS ON
FRIDAY FOR SCIENCE.
>> THIS DOES NOT SOUND LIKE
SCIENCE.
TO SPEAK OF THE 12 YEARS NUMBER
IS WHAT SCIENTIST SAID BASED ONT
IS WHAT SCIENTIST SAID BASED ONE
CLIMATE ACCORD.
THIS IS WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET BY 2030, THIS HAPPENED IN
2018, SO BY 2030 WE WANT TO BE
HERE.
SOMEHOW THAT NUMBER BECAME IF WE
DON'T DO IT IN 12 YEARS THE END
OF THE WORLD IS IMMINENT, AND
BETO O'ROURKE HAS SAID THAT,
NUMEROUS DEMOCRATS HAVE RUN ON
THE ISSUE.
WHEN BETO ANNOUNCED THE CLIP
THAT YOU JUST SHOWED, HE SAID
THAT THERE WAS UNANIMOUS
CONSENSUS AMONG SCIENTISTS THAT
WE HAD 12 YEARS LEFT TO FIX
THIS.
IT IS NONSENSE THAT THEY HAVE
REPEATED THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND IT NEVER GETS AS YOU
SETTING YOUR FIRST SEGMENT, AND
NEVER GETS CORRECTED AND NOBODY
APOLOGIZES.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SAYING THAT BILL NYE IS
ACTUALLY A SCIENCE GUY, NOT JUST
A BUFFOON CREATED BY TELEVISION.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO ASK THESE
FOLKS, I REMEMBER A REPORT IN
1989 AND I WAS A FRESHMAN IN
HIGH SCHOOL THAT SAID THAT WE
HAD TEN YEARS LEFT BY THE YEAR
2,000 AND WE HAD A FIXED CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WHAT DID THEY GET WRONG THEN
THAT THEY ARE SO CERTAIN THAT
THEY HAVE NOW THAT WE HAVE TWO
FIXED CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT OF WHAT THEY SAY IS JUST AN
EFFORT TO IMMEDIATELY TAKE THE
MORAL HIGH GROUND AND HOLDING
THE MORAL HIGH GROUND DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO THE
COUNTRY.
>> WHEN YOU DO THINGS UNDER THE
GUISE OF PROTECTING MOTHER EARTH
OR FOR THE PLANET, OR FOR THEIR
CHILDREN, REMEMBER THE KIDS WHO
STORMED DIANNE FEINSTEIN'S
OFFICE A LITTLE WHILE AGO WHEN
YOU DO THINGS FOR THE PLANET YOU
ARE GIVEN A REALLY WIDE BERTH.
SO IT IS TAKING OVER THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY AND ALL
EMPLOYMENT.
IT IS PUTTING OUT OF WORK
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY.
IT'S FUNNY THAT BETTER WAS NOT
TALKING ABOUT THESE THINGS WHEN
HE WAS RUNNING AGAINST TED CRUZ
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO.
>> >> Tucker: I THINK OF MY
MYSELF AS SOMEBODY WHO LOVES THE
OUTDOORS, WIRE THE CITY IS
FILTHY THAT THEY RUN, THEY ARE
CESSPOOLS.
>> AND WHY DON'T PEOPLE DICTATE
WHAT THEY WANT TO MANDATE,
BERNIE SANDERS APPLIED ON
PRIVATE JETS, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ PREFERS TO TAKE
THE SHUTTLE ON AMERICAN ISLANDS
TO AMTRAK.
I DON'T BLAME HER.
I WOULD WATCH MORE TAKE THE
SHUTTLE AS WELL.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T WANT TO
GO TO PENN STATION BECAUSE IT IS
DISGUSTING.
AND THERE IS HUMAN WASTE AND
HYPERBOLIC BEETLES.
OR SHOULD I TAKE NOBODY
SERIOUSLY IF THEY DO NOT PICK UP
THE TRASH IN FRONT OF THEIR OWN
BUILDING?
>> WHAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO RUN
THEIR CITIES, BUT IF THEY GIVE
MORE POWER TO EMPLOY THE ENTIRE
NATION INCLUDING THOSE UNWILLING
TO WORK, SOMEHOW THEY WILL FIX
THINGS?
THEY CAN'T RUN AMTRAK WELL NOW,
WHAT MAKES US THINK THAT THEY
WILL BUILD A NATIONAL AUTOMOTIVE
GRADE OR TRAIN RAILROADS.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE ARE ON THE
DEFENSE AS SOON AS THEY START
TALKING AND THEY SAY, CLIMATE IS
A PROBLEM.
INSTEAD OF SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT AND THERE IS NO REFERENCE
OR SCIENCE TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, YOU'RE A DEMAGOGUE AND A
LIAR?
WHY DOES NOBODY SAY THAT?
>> I WISH THAT THEY WOULD POINT
OUT WHAT FOSSIL FUELS JUST FOR
OUR COUNTRY AND THE QUALITY OF
LIFE, THE KIDS THAT WERE
MARCHING ON SATURDAY WERE ALL
WITH SMARTPHONES.
THERE WAS A GIRL WHO HAD A
PLASTIC FIJI WATER BOTTLE, DOES